welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
the missing link to improving efficiency
and productivity in the digital lab
presented by J Campbell chief commercial
officer so Mark innovations my name is
xavier gutierrez and i will be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
lab roots is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits app located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Jay Campbell I will
now turn the presentation over to him
the chain of custody in our labs is the
unbroken link between all the objects
used in your research your people the
animal models cell lines reagents
compounds the lab instruments and
devices the data records where data is
stored the link between the analytics
and the data collected in the smart lab
there's no place for uncertainty smart
requires your research and data to be
specific measurable auditable repeatable
but preclinical research is a long way
from being smart to give you two
examples in preclinical research the use
of rodents accounts for over 70% of all
in vivo research and the most common
methods of animal identification
or permanent pen marks ear notches in
metal ear tags
research has shown these methods of
identification are prone to miss reading
eros at rates between 20 and 40 percent
in addition to animal models the NIH
recently reported significant levels of
miss on identification with cell lines
the lack of reliable identification of
inputs to your research is further
compounded by the lack of data quality
control rising from the use of paper lab
notebooks and spreadsheets manual
recording of experimental data manual
input of results data they leave the
process open to human error
transcription issues and do not provide
audit trails and lack transparency so
the lack of confidence in your data
quality arising from your analog methods
of identification poor data management
and limited rigor applied to the process
of experimental design execution and
analysis is really creating a house of
cards the wrong Mouse the wrong weight
the wrong tumor measurement all leading
to the wrong conclusions which is
certainly evident in the invivo
preclinical research the missing links
are at the heart of the reproductive
ability crisis we see an in vivo
research so how do we ensure smart lab
is alcoa compliant and don't forget CC
EA to complete consistent enduring and
available at so mark we have worked with
over 300 customers over the past six
years to better understand what makes a
lab smart and how to deliver that
capability in an affordable way we
believe the answer or the missing link
in the lab that prevents us from being
smart efficient accurate transparent
rigorous reproducible is digital
identity
Asian digital identification is the
technology that is connected seamlessly
to automated data collection processing
and analytical processes at the heart of
the so mark smart lab is a common method
of digital identification we propose the
adoption of the rain' rfid standard for
identifying all your lab objects
including your staff your animals your
samples and your devices passive
ultra-high frequency tags are already
used in billions of devices and
extensively in logistics to track assets
in real time and space it's a proven
low-cost accessible and scalable
technology platform already at the heart
of industry 4.0 and will become part of
the standard in the lab 4.0 revolution 2
at so mark we've developed the world's
first ultra high frequency animal tag
this provides preclinical in vivo
research a digital method of
identification that is low-cost more
humane for the animal and most
importantly is interoperable with other
brain RFID tags that can be used with
caged cards samples and lab instrument
assets tracking so you may be using
current available RFID technology in
your labs for animal identification but
these are not the same ultra-high
frequency or rain' compliant for example
they would not integrate with a sample
or a personnel identification badges
additionally the current RFID tags are
not purposely built or designed
specifically for animals which is an
animal welfare concern so now you've
solved the missing link in your lab and
all your objects are digital you have to
be able to connect those objects to your
research processes the right people the
right example experiments the right data
records to solve that challenge we
developed since ALAB which is a
technology platform providing tag
connectivity to lab devices and animals
and other inputs to a cloud-based data
system that correctly stores the records
and maintains full audit trails since
the lab is built to deliver automated
processes
across the entire chain of custody all
you need is to tag your objects plug in
your readers and devices and connect to
the internet since the lab enables you
to move away from paper and Excel sheets
to secure scalable cloud environment and
will connect with the technology you
already have your existing devices and
systems if you're lucky enough to have
good data systems so what does this look
like in practice utilizing our low-cost
benchtop tag reader or you could buy a
handheld reader our device enables you
to turn your existing lab instruments
into Internet of Things devices by
connecting them to our I connect system
the I connect captures the ID of the
person the animal the object and the
data from the lab device and
automatically puts the data in the right
record with an accurate time and date
stamp in the cloud database one of the
key steps towards implementing the smart
lab after adding digital IDs to your
objects is to use systems like I connect
to then automate the collection of data
from experiments and post them to the
right records in the cloud database with
a full audit trail that's what I connect
us in our smart lab we don't simply
upload a spreadsheet into an electronic
lab notebook we use since a lab to
ensure every data record is tracked
inversion independently with a full
audit trail recording where it came from
who recorded it when and from which
digitally identified subject for example
a mouse or what other inputs are
associated such as which cell line our
compound remember simply uploading files
to an electronic lab notebooks does not
give you full control over the source
data and the files and one of the
benefits of moving to a smart lab is not
just a mutable data it's actually much
more efficient we recently conducted 12
pilot studies across US and Europe
results were 69
74 percent reduction in time to take
data with a zero percent read or data
input errors not only did we achieve
process efficiency now you have a smart
lab with efficiently managed digital
data and now you may ask so what
well the real value comes from the
analysis of the data in the late 80s or
early 90s there was an often quoted
saying in the early days of data science
and I'm sure you will recognize it and
that was garbage N equals garbage out
there's significant excitement and
rightfully so about machine learning and
AI
but if you're training algorithms on
poor data quality really how good are
your algorithms I have provided two
reference articles in the presentation
that focus specifically on this crisis
and science the key strategic advantage
of a smart lab based on digital ID and
automated data collection is the data
authenticity accuracy and reliability
and what you will see is the higher
quality of data will drive insights
faster you can even start to move
towards near real-time discovery of
exceptions of errors of trends IBBs
a laboratory information technology
company estimated that saving one week
in drug discovery process is worth six
million dollars one of the advantages of
this move to digital data is you move
away from using Excel and manual
manipulation of data preparation and
transfer the minute you download data
from your repository again you open up a
[ __ ] in the chain of custody so the
final missing link that stops the chain
of custody from being broken is to keep
your research data in a secure data
environment and actually to point your
analysis tools at it preserving the
integrity of the data we propose using
data visualization tools you can gain
insights into your data quicker tools
such as power bi or tableau enable you
to set alerts when they detect anomalies
and data preventing your research going
out of control losing animals to ill
health unnecessarily and will save you
time and sometimes the value of your
research
if your data is locked in paper
notebooks or files on servers are even
files uploaded to an electronic lab
notebook you will struggle to develop
reliable analytical insights and of
course when you start to apply
predictive analytic tools machine
learning and AI to augment the scope of
your analysis and identify hidden
correlations you did not expect basing
these discoveries unreliable accurate
data with your digital ID is that the
heart of your data integrity will begin
to minimize false positives and false
negatives and ensure reproducible
research in conclusion the smart lab
requires a range of capabilities to be
in place we have talked about the need
for secure scalable data management
platforms automated data collection
devices and data visualization and
analytical tools but at the heart of the
smart lab must be the digital ID it
needs to be consistent integrated
identification method in our view based
on the rain rfid standard passive UHF
EPC Gentoo iso 18000 s63 without it the
link between your research and data
quality is at risk and your chain of
custody can break all too easy thank you
for your time Thank You Jay for that
informative presentation no it also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May of 2019 and as a
final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you've submitted
via email that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye